holy bunco's kids look out the keep it
moving tour is adding new dates
we're coming to a city near you
come and see us some stand-up and we
play ayg at the end of the show with the
crowd we answer your garbage questions
we've got some trash so far but i know i
know
there's deeper garbage out there around
the country oh yeah so come on out and
see us kippy tell them what they need to
know oh baby we're all over the place
new brunswick new jersey august 25th
down tomatoes timonium maryland
magooby's august 26th couple of crabs
and we're going to tejas baby
uh september 21st will be in san antonio
texas september 22nd will be in houston
texas september 23rd through the 25th
austin texas for the moon tower comedy
festival and i ain't done yet august
26th will be at fort dallas fort worth
texas what then we're bringing it back
to long island baby
and all uh september 30th and then we're
coming home the boys are caught the
chickens are coming home to roost baby
october 27th we're gonna be in
philadelphia pennsylvania and then back
down to tejas uh november 5th through
the 7th for skank fest south get those
tickets the link will be in the
description welcome to another exciting
edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
r u garbage sure is it's a little show
we sat down with your favorite comedians
when you find out they grow up to be
classy or if they're just a big old
piece of [ __ ] i'm your host dave foley
coming at you on a beautiful day we're
down here at aunt tony's basement the
summer is winding down we're feeling
good here sure i got a little bit of a
pimple problem on my forehead i saw do
not attempt to adjust your screen crater
face foley over here
my co-host is coming at you rudely from
across the table at me he is the ceo of
ru garbage
he's a fellow international businessman
fellow i'm joining the ranks baby well
let's once you travel then you can
become paris come see me my co-host you
can have an international intern
he messed up my flow there first time i
messed up the intro kevin james ryan i
want to call him record that is not the
first time he messed up videotapes
videotapes you have t-bone caught two or
three tries
time recorded never blew it in front of
a guest either
that's a long 30 seconds yeah act like i
don't pull my weight around here huh
well it's either you or a backhoe hey
what's up everybody
happy to be here thanks for tuning in as
always please make sure you review
subscribe on itunes full video available
on youtube and as you know those numbers
are true
true the [ __ ] roof then patreon.com
where the rubber hits the road baby
just hit
2100 patrons 2 100 patrons these are
gonna be doing a little golf a little
golf coming up we're planning the ayg
invitational uh it'll be a good time a
little bit of an aldine type situation
trying to get honor palmer trying to get
ap yeah uh
and then also guys get some [ __ ]
merch there's cards available yeah
koozie's available yeah the link will be
in the description and live shows we got
a little what a lot of live shows coming
up [ __ ] texas coming up man we're
gonna be in texas for like a whole week
chaos yeah
sounds nice gonna be a good one little
tex mex down there sure get a couple
burritos bow reno's yeah how about a
nice quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire he's the magic man he
makes us all look good give it up for
t-bone mcmuffin god damn it it's toby
mcmullen t-bone what's up dudes what's
good buddy ah back of the damn buick
dude good to be back back in the damn
buick back here in the office gang this
is a family episode it's just me and
kippy we're gonna be answering your
questions yeah from the old patreon a
couple from the old facebook group or as
i like to call it the wild west no we're
not
i gotta work through that patreon
background okay i just said we got 21 on
patrons i wanted to ask you what did you
want to ask me um
it's sneezing in your shirt trash
oh you do it a lot i do it a lot nah you
don't even do this you just do you try
it
a sneeze you're the only guy who who
doesn't know a sneeze is happening
especially for how big yours are you
feel like you would feel that in your
toes i do feel them coming well you're
always you're always i just watched pink
miss come out that did it did nothing
[ __ ] check t-bone's computer screen
that thing needs a sneeze guard
like the salad bar wendy's yeah
um sorry go no i wanted to ask you that
and i also wanted to ask you my cousin
brought this up to me shout out to my
cousin michael have you ever gone in to
pay for something not had enough cash
and then say to the guy i'll be back in
one minute and never to return
[Laughter]
i thought i was 7-eleven in boys town
chicago 25 yeah
still got your big bite sitting on the
counter
that was a big thing anytime my card
would get declined i'd be like i got
cash i was i've also faked it sometimes
because let me go get cash out then like
go fake the atm and then when he's not
watching i sneak out the door shout out
to the halloween wawa by the way
[ __ ] that idiot didn't see it pulling
the car out of that lot no you feel like
a [ __ ] dirt there's a feeling when
you when you i did happen in yesterday
when you don't have your wallet on you
where you're like uh somebody help but
like because i i got back from the uh
the dr yesterday and uh that's dominican
republic for you non-international
training sure i also wanted to say this
is
trash related we'll get into we'll get
into the trip on
oh yeah um talking about the rubber
meeting the river
the freak got into the century folks
um spicy
it's like the adam and eve channel over
there caliente you're catching my drift
this weekend
it shows how trash i am that i went to
an all-inclusive resort and still
somehow ended up in the back of a pickup
truck
that's in you you can
that's it you can't be doing that by the
way that's in that's
i gotta i can't lie i was kind of
excited i'm like i'll get in the back
this time you can't be doing that [ __ ]
anymore
you got you got you people your response
you're a father now at this point you're
responsible people
i got this trip playing don't [ __ ]
what was the last time you were in the
back of a pickup truck it's a good
[ __ ] time i gotta tell you it was
pretty funny so we
were leaving the one place we were going
into town to get uh covet tests and uh
sounds fun
no well you guys really tearing it up
over there you get back in the country
you gotta get one go with tests and flu
shots so i'm gonna cover test and one of
the waiters for one of the waiters from
the all-inclusive resort because they
have like moped uh
taxis where like i guess for a couple of
pesos you hop on the back of it really
oh it's all mopeds it's like it's like
[ __ ] taiwan wait you gotta pay to
hold a guy's waste it's crazy the look i
mean we'll get into it but the streets
are something else
um
but
uh i'm in the bathroom now we're like in
the city center it's all hectic you know
cars are breaking down
and uh this is
one of the waiters who i greased up but
pretty heavy so he knew me in the main
cat like in the main restaurant
uh
he pulls up on the back of a motorcycle
next to me on like the highway he's like
what the [ __ ] dude he literally looked
at me like what the [ __ ] are you doing
in the back of a pickup truck right now
we're looking for the pool
does this guy work with you the sauna
this way
he was like dude he literally did what
the [ __ ] are you doing i don't know man
i'm hanging out baby i'm garbage
ah it's good stuff it was a good time
but uh to get back i so i wanted to drop
my bags and i'm like i need some [ __ ]
usa food baby give me some [ __ ]
slices of zombies what are you got back
here i got back to the states boots on
the ground in the states you know what i
mean good old usa went over there to uh
the pizza place got three slices of diet
started today got three slices of pizza
um
got the vodka slice
got a grandma mm-hmm
and a cecilia that all checks out that's
[ __ ] that's serious slice right there
that ain't too plain in a pepperoni holy
[ __ ] that's a lot of dough and i ain't
talking about the ghee i'll tell you
that
christ oh jesus a grandma and a sicilian
no well there's sicilian there's no
cheese it's just like tomato kill johnny
cash i think jesus christ you can't do
that
can't [ __ ] wash down a grandma on a
vodka slice yeah that vodka that vodka
sauce should just be sauce that should
just be on everything that should be
every pizza i don't know i don't know
some places put the actual pasta on
there too i hate that that's real trash
i don't mind it if we're [ __ ] being
honest [ __ ] big zd what order do you
eat what order do you eat those three
slices in you got to give the sicilian
slices like kind of tomato pie stack
them all up
and boof them
i take my penne i take my penny slice
rectally please stuff them in a condom
and jam it right up there uh which way
would i go about that what order would
you do that in
cause i had a kick i had to kick around
a little bit yeah now if i'm alone i
could be doing bite to bite i could
really maybe that's animalistic you're
going to themselves dude no
these are like murder cases you [ __ ]
open it and close it at the same time
first first 48. you can't be dipping
your toes in other cases
yeah um
i would do the i would you're nuts dude
i would do that that's crazy i would do
the vibe i thought this was a
judgment-free environment
you thought wrong
bite the bite
that's like changing holes in an origin
what's wrong with that
supposed to do your job but keep make
sure the lights are off
the lights are off
i would do the vodka slice first
and then the grandma and then [ __ ] to
put to put me to put me out i would
knock down a sicilian okay probably
leave a couple of bites of that couple
dr peppers couple dps yeah and hit hit
right on the couch and dr peppers be out
uh okay i'd be into i'd be in sleep land
i saved the vodka for less sugar coma
has this zest to it huh
the most flavorful one i save for the
end oh okay yeah cause then you have
something nice and it's bland after that
i'm like give me the i already had the
high heat now you're throwing me a
[ __ ] you know what i mean you're
throwing me a change up i couldn't do it
like that because i would be too full
from the i had you could do it like that
let's not get crazy oh i could yeah
let's not get i couldn't do it like that
i mean you know
get hired for a job you're gonna do it
with what you got to do sure got to get
done going to get done that's the kippy
motto
then break for lunch
yeah but well i went to the pizza place
i forgot my [ __ ] wallet
after i ordered
then i had to give it i was hoping for
him to be like i'll get you next time i
don't like that i don't like get me next
time because then i think that i owe
that then i'm that's in the back of my
head well you do owe the money i mean i
know and i'm not locked loaded and
hunting for you yeah but i don't like
that but i'm in that establishment i
mean i walk by it at least five times a
day yeah then then the next time you
walk by and you forgot the money and you
pop in say hey i owe you for the [ __ ]
i owe you for uh but what if you forget
your wallet again or something like that
because i've done that where i
felt like i could get in your wallet
multiple times it's your fault i feel
like i couldn't walk by the pizza place
or bodega
unless i had their money because
you know i don't want that sure give me
a bad neighbor give me a bad name in the
neighborhood yeah already ruined your
reputable uh reputation you got going on
there my boy did that for me not that
long ago
months ago but i don't know who you're
what you're talking about pizza place
you're oh yeah yeah another money first
i only have like
you didn't have the 12 grand on you
listen i love my bitcoin at home
[Laughter]
can i sign over my car please don't hurt
my family
[Laughter]
can i squeeze a beef patty out of you
but back to originally what we were
discussing you can't be riding on
[ __ ] you can't be doing that
skydiving roller coasters
we should be even doing that was in the
back of a pickup truck that's dangerous
you go down there it did is you go
flying on that thing and crack your head
up what the [ __ ] me and t-bone gonna do
i don't wanna learn how to
i don't know learn how to do everything
i do i guess
hire somebody get the card did he have a
chase manhattan car
did he mention a pin number to you
did he have a tattoo was there a barcode
on him anywhere
you're bleeding out tell foley the money
is small
it goes to my wife
damn
ice that fat bastard am i in your will
what i don't have the will i take it
easy like everything goes everything
goes abroad really yeah wow she moves
her over
some [ __ ] she already
um
all right let's see this is a [ __ ]
mora on the dr trip
excellent hard feeling or excellent
excellent as you say before we jump into
the patreon questions i got questions
for the two of you guys i thought the
other day
have you ever moved without using moving
boxes what was this guy first day on the
job
the door we've been in here almost a
year i got to tell you how we keep the
lights on in this dump yeah [ __ ]
trash bags shopping bags [ __ ] guitar
cases filled with [ __ ] my moving boxes
how do you even get them my mom used to
send me down to the grocery store see if
they have any boxes
you guys are moving a bunch of chiquita
banana boxes
you got all your stuff on your head
[ __ ] spiders falling out
yeah
you got generic cereal box [ __ ]
yeah yeah man of course when i first
moved up here i thought i was classy
because i went out and bought
at u-haul they [ __ ] no i break you
over to kohl's for those i went out to
like bed bath and beyond or the
container store or something and bought
like they were kind of the length of the
table like big clear
kind of like they weren't coolers but
like big
tupperware what are they called it's not
topper hubs tubs big tubs you're moving
with tubs
i thought i was the [ __ ] those things
stink i had two big tubs i stacked them
up
i could snack my whole life when i moved
from the apartment i was in the heights
of my boy to astoria or the first time i
got my own place i moved in two of those
and like three button-ups on hangers
that was i that was everything i owned
could fit into two tubs nice took the
bed from the kid that was living there
before maybe i got one delivery in the
tub
no the bed i think the kid left his bed
frame and i got a new mattress or
something like that yeah i don't know
moms for that i remember i was like i
need a mattress
not no more not no more that's helix.com
maybe that's next week
um
all right
let's get into it yeah cause i just we
just moved t-bone and he moved that was
a little shoddy yeah what a yeah you
[ __ ] moved like an animal you moved
like you owed rent
like that like you were getting evicted
you
stank
um all right let's get into it as you
know this is a patreon episode or
there's not a patreon it's a family
episode where we were ansel answer your
garbage questions from patreon sometimes
a facebook group but we got a lot to get
through on a patreon here let's do it
couple of dingers by the way
first one is from jack campbell ever
upgrade to the 10 patreon level every
three months to binge hard feelings and
go back down to five
no but i respect it while you're costing
me a couple of bucks
i respected my man do you game the
system i didn't make the system i'm
trying to game it myself
um all right this one's from johnny my
trash question is have you ever hooked
up with one of your mom's friends your
mum's it was mom so i think he's a brit
from the island yeah or australia ooh
yeah hot australian was there any mom
you took a run or could have taken a run
at
beside your own shout out to paddy
no no they were i mean my one buddy had
a super hot mom but she was way out of
hard like she was like super hot yeah
her his dad was like an alpha like a
male like you know like a real man yeah
sure not us no yeah no
no no no no no no no not us at all yeah
uh i don't think there was any we never
had a couple of you weren't pulling any
[ __ ] mind tailback i'm just saying
even an option there was a couple of hot
moms but like again way too hot like
stacy's mom type stuff did you ever cry
in front of somebody else's mom and had
to be comforted by her had a sleepover
or something not as a kid probably they
ran out of dinner rolls
get me some amarosos
shout out to the amaroso um i'm a king's
hawaiian man myself
um i'm sure like
my super tight friends is like kit like
six seven eight like six that age i'm
sure at some point you bitched up
somewhere we i probably got hurt or like
like there were certain kids that we
were just like together all like
neighborhood kids were like
at their house or in the backyard or
what i'm sure yeah something nothing
rings a bell it's a tough look yeah it's
not go i mean i'm yeah seriously then
try to make a move on it
20 years later
hey remember when i [ __ ] my pants and
was crying did you ever pee your pants
somewhere where you weren't supposed to
no but you have no i haven't
where are you supposed to be your pants
some places pay good money for that
[Laughter]
well it jumped in my head of like have
you ever peed your pants at like a
friend's house at school and you had to
get the
i remember if kids
ruined their clothes in like mud i don't
think anybody peed their pants but you
would have to switch into like a pair of
sweatpants from the lost and found or
whatever the gym coaches
i had to do that i would go over like my
boy's house and like let's go swim we
weren't planning on it and i have to
wear like the dad's swim trunks or
whatever
you got a blazer on
well we were like six i'm like you got
anything in an xl
ah it's a tough look
seven year old double leg bad uncles
that left some clothes here
oh man that's tough no when i was like
at husky was the big word oh yeah i
thought it meant cool tough skin is what
we called them yeah tough skin if they
have like uh like extra maybe that's
what give you all the skin tags extra
extra padding in the knees
[Laughter]
nothing on earth
[Laughter]
we got to start recording with the air
on i'm schmidt that's a new thing by the
way
no never i only i [ __ ] my pants once in
uh
as an adult yeah sure all the time yeah
yeah not as a kid that's more
embarrassing poop your pants at 40.
things happen everybody understands that
yeah i thought the opposite i think i
think you get a [ __ ] in your pants pass
until you're like 13.
right 13 12 11 i don't know
seven seven well that's still hot
i think yeah that's high i mean i'm
i don't know dump a roosky anyway i
dumped in my pants and i was catching
bernie's already i can't be [ __ ]
[ __ ] myself and smoking more breads
wearing somebody's dad's clothes smoking
burnies and [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] at my
buddies [ __ ] in my buddy's dad's
bathing suit hey
i [ __ ] your underwear i apologize
let me get one of those cowboy killers
huh
tell the old brawl to get the stove top
cooking huh
you fill up the phillips detroit where's
she out anyway she's a good looking bra
i'm trying to make a move on her i [ __ ]
my pants in kindergarten didn't say a
word kept it real low-key
[Laughter]
nobody sent me home nobody said nobody
wanted to get anywhere near you dude
smell like a [ __ ] porta potty
oh my god you're just sitting in your
cage [ __ ] dumped in it
and it was so long before i got home and
it like dried and was like stuck to my
ass how to power watch it
no you know what's weird it's like an
elephant in the mob movie of your life
you're like and that's the day i learned
to keep my mouth shut
and ever since then i'd never ratted on
nobody
everybody's like hey foley always never
rats i heard he [ __ ] himself at seven
years old didn't say a beep i learned
the two rules of being a gangster always
keep your mouth shut and never [ __ ] in
your pants
nobody said anything and i they were
thinking stuff i know that much
but why wouldn't the teacher come over
and say something because it was so long
that i remember when i finally took the
underwear off they had like dried like
the poop had like dried in there and it
was like sticking to my butt and i threw
it in the hamper my mom never said a
word to me to this day we've never
discussed she had to find that in there
sure man how about that surprise on a
[ __ ] wednesday trying to be a good
mom doing the laundry
[ __ ] baboon
but i must have stunk right [ __ ]
yeah man you stink now and you don't
have [ __ ] in your pants that may not be
true
one can either confirm nor deny these
allegations you've set forth upon me and
that's the day i learned you could [ __ ]
your pants
that's the joke and that's the day i
learned you [ __ ] your pants
don't say nothing keep your mouth shut
be a good kid
no one's none the wise
everybody shits their pants kid nobody
cares
gang this summer bespoke post is here to
take your summer adventures to the next
level with their box of awesome oh yeah
they're absolutely fantastic bespoke
pokes likes to partner with small
businesses to create the most amazing
box of awesome they can possibly make
and send them right to you yeah uh they
work with a lot of like new small
emerging brands to get products that
they tailor directly to you it's easy
peasy uh no matter what you're into a
box of awesome has you covered from
travel to outdoor uh breezy summer
styles grooming goods grills whatever
you're into they got for you they sent
it to us they sent us a bunch of cool
[ __ ] i chose the outdoor thing and the
travel i i got a i got a sweet sweet ass
duffel bag they gave us a cool knife a
hammock a blanket i mean so much stuff
you'll love it sign up it's
top-notch stuff to donate the hammock is
up at club foley and they love me uh to
get started just take the quiz at box of
awesome.com your answers will help them
pick the right box of awesome for you
they release new boxes every month
across a ton of different categories so
you can mix and match and choose
whatever you want it's free to sign up
uh you can skip a month or cancel at any
time each box only costs 45 bucks
talking 45 clams that's easy peasy
that's out the door and every uh and
every box has over 70 worth of gear i
was gonna say so what are we doing how
much gear's in there they hook it up
yeah they don't skimp that's nice no
yeah yeah it's a pretty cool thing give
it a shot
whatever you're into they can make it
work uh so guys you'll get twenty twenty
percent
that most 20 percent what are we doing
that's
bonkers they're giving it away you get
20 off your first monthly box when you
sign up at box of awesome.com and enter
the promo code garbage at checkout
that's promo code garbage one more time
box of awesome.com promo code garbage 20
off your first box yeah do it kippy
let's talk about raycon every day
earbuds you know who has a pair the big
man the big man and i love him i love
the little pod that it comes in i love
how long the battery lasts 32 hours i'm
listening to my tunes yeah quality is
unbelievable i love it i feel literally
like i'm running things with my i know
you do feel so important when i gave
them to you i never had ear buds before
and he's never had headphones never had
never had earbuds i gave him to him he
thinks he's an international businessman
they fit perfectly in your ear you
started calling everybody hey from my
raycons i just want to call you from my
rake and let you know i'm on my rake i
love it because the other guys you can
feel them in your ears i know not right
kyle they're like in there perfect you
feel like you're in the cia or something
and fantastic now that things are
getting back to normal you know commutes
to work the whole nine yards vacation
travel
you know podcast you listen to podcasts
listen to your music you're exercising
ray cons are the best way to listen i'm
telling you that right now uh they come
with a bunch of gel tips you know to
feel comfortable of course whatever
works for you
um like you said 32-hour battery life
believable and they start at half the
price of premium audio brands fantastic
but they sound just as good that's how
they get your hands out awesome just as
good because i've compared they sound
better i'm telling you that right now
and that's me saying that that's a big
man uh raycon's come with a 45-day
happiness guarantee so you can't really
lose give them a try and you'll see what
we mean um you can create your own
soundtrack with raycon right now uh ayg
listeners all your garbage dishes we'll
get 15 off the raycon order at buy
raycon.com garbage do it that's 15 off
they're already low what are we doing
giving it away uh buy raycon.com garbage
one more time 50 off that's by
raycon.com garbage 50 off promo code
garbage
kippy let me tell you
stamps.comstamps.com i'll say it again
for the back of the room hit it
stamps.com come on you don't want to
waste time in the post office
all right we have stamps.com they sent
us all the stuff
wrapped up all the cards sent them all
out we were in the post office for about
30 seconds yeah can i tell you something
even better you don't even have to go to
the post office you can send up a pickup
what it'll come right to you what pick
it up when it's convenient for you
stamps.com saves
businesses thousands of hours and tons
of money every year every year uh they
bring the service of the us post office
and ups right to your computer it's a
must-have for any business i know we
have a lot of small business owners out
there uh whether you're a small office
sending invoices side hustle etsy shop
whatever you're doing you had it set up
on a computer that you were spitting
those things out left and right i felt
like newman and seinfeld baby i was just
i was i it was easy peasy uh stamp south
tom can handle it all with ease no
wonder no wonder why over one million
businesses choose stamps.com for their
mailing and shipping needs um all you
need is your computer uh some internet
the printer uh you can print us postage
24 7 and any letter any package any
class in the mail anywhere you want to
send it once your mail is ready like i
said just schedule pick up boom or you
can drop it off easy peasy out the door
out the door don't waste stamp.com
you'll get up to 40 off post office
rates and up to 66 percent off ups
shipping rates that's bonkos i'm sending
stuff just for the heck of it now you
know what i mean be losing money if you
didn't i know i'm sending myself lunch
and stuff something to somebody i know
sams.com is a no-brainer saving time and
money
um there's no risk and with our promo
code garbage you'll get a special offer
that includes a four-week trial plus
free postage and a digital scale no
long-term commitments or contracts
required i tell you that like you said
they sent it to us it's easy-peasy open
it up plug it in
you got free postage there you go the
whole nine yards go to stamps.stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page type in garbage one more
time stance.com promo code garbage
stamps.com never go to the post office
again now back to the show
oh man you are
another kind of you're paying in your
pants places no i'm not yeah you are you
basically admitted
why would i not i bet you're the kind of
weird kid because you know like every
once in a while i peed the bed i'll get
me a bed right now i'll pay it there was
always that one kid
uh like when they when kids are little
but like i remember
little kids have different little moves
like when they were still in diapers and
and they had to take a [ __ ] they walk
into the corner yeah they walked under
the couch or whatever yeah but like i
had this one cousin who would stand
there and look at you
he would he'd stand there and get like
this through your soul he'd get like
this weird look at his face and you just
see like
and then like three seconds later you
get like a [ __ ]
frying pan to the face
it was a little kid [ __ ] don't smell
good no they like fruity pebbles [ __ ]
bad look
oh god that's funny great question this
is all in the same this is a perfect
perfect segue this is from producer perm
uh do you go over the top or through the
fly to pee i think we've covered this
have we over the top
i unbutton
unbutton what what do you mean my he's
not talking about the jeans dummy what
are you a psycho underwear this guy
likes it rough huh i didn't know i
didn't think of that at all the denim on
my scrotum
no he's talking about underwear the
other side of my bowl
talking about your underwear gotcha and
any if you're going through that little
[ __ ] that little doggie door
you're a psycho yeah i remember seeing
that when i was a kid being like this is
like a [ __ ] medieval torture chamber
i'm not putting my little guy in that
yeah not with that parental supervision
that's like a guillotine yeah
if the elastic's too tight take the head
right off yeah
this is the french revolution huh
yeah no you go down and air it out you
get some you got yourself you get some
daylight on yeah you go over there
you're sneaking out no that's weird also
too as you get older there's no fits
through that little thing anyway i mean
i'm no show-off no i can't get through
there
you kidding me i'm trying to think in
the sheaths now i always it's not even a
process to go
over the top too pull them right down um
my buddy's dad when he's wearing shorts
he goes under there i go under i do too
really yeah 100 i'd be like a urinal
down at keenan's next to him and he's
like i'm like yeah what the [ __ ] are you
doing jesus christ like a soccer player
yeah yeah like dude hello [ __ ] like
he's got cargo shorts on
just [ __ ]
yeah i go under two
that's crazy it's easier
no mess no mess no fuss no mess nope for
jesus christ you're
caught in a glitch
um
yeah i uh yeah if you're going through
the hole that's bonko's to me if you
have boxers on that's a little different
you wear boxers don't you oh boxers make
sense because it's there's nothing to go
through it's not the z there's not the
dog leg left down there oh yeah whatever
that is
so if you have a boxer it's like a door
in space you know there's those
what
[Laughter]
did
[Music]
um
boxers yeah because it's just the window
that makes more sense right there's not
like the double flap sure yeah that's
what i'm saying boxers i would now
thinking back i would i would go through
the box and you still wear boxers oh
yeah you can't put the python in the
cage jesus christ boxers they're old men
boxers too i know they're like now that
they're like white with the gray lines
on them yeah no not plaid
hanes nice
classic i got new one of these oh great
yeah what brand are you going with
they're hanging halliburton
these come with [ __ ] already in them
they're caterpillar
what halliburton was great i mean come
on i don't know
nine million dollar no big contract
um
no they're haynes and they're tighties
yeah i need a little support in there
i got a little bit of an issue going on
we'll discuss it later okay
but right now i'm all snug and nice
feels good no tag either and no
waistband to bunch up around my
so what what do you have
this doesn't even sound like underwear
just a soccer throw yeah what do you
mean no there's no there's no i mean
there's a waistband but it's small it's
not like the big strip they're not like
old-school shitty tighty whities they're
new cool tighty ladies
i'll do it so your mother told you no
all the kids are wearing them
we were strict tidy whities growing up i
bet you oh the tighter the better
that's how she liked them
all smooshed in there all right jesus is
brutal what were you wearing as a kid i
told you well i had the infamous pair of
silk boxers that i would wear as a
seven-year-old
what are you asking about people's moms
i remember i thought i told this story
where we went swimming and i had them
all like we like jumped in the pool and
then we had to change and like they like
gave me a pair of my buddy shorts we
were like seven or like kids
you know they're like oh change into you
know here's a pair of clothes of
changing and i remember handing her like
he was going to throw them in the dryer
like hang them out on the clothesline
she
they were a pair of like the [ __ ]
floral [ __ ] silk boxers hey go ahead
doll face
take a sniff if you want huh i remember
her looking at me like holding them up
like what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] are the
ryan's just fat little [ __ ] getting into
it
killing it no toby you ever sleep with
uh your friend's mom
okay that's a yes
um
all right this one's from grayson uh
first first patreon question is it
garbage for your step dad to also have a
step dad
that's usually how that [ __ ] works oh
that is no that's bad as someone with a
stepdad i would be severely more [ __ ]
up if he had a stepdad
for sure that's true [ __ ] nobody's
related what's going on here um
that's super that's a [ __ ] home run
of a question funny
um
this one i mean this is his first
question i want to get we haven't
touched on in a while this is a trash
move and i don't do it this is from
pavlo
uh did you ever ask for a water cup just
to fill it up with soda at the taco bell
it's trash man trash don't do that i
mean spend the two bucks
yeah what are we doing we got gotta try
to hold ourselves to some sort of thing
because here's the thing every once in a
while you're gonna get some [ __ ] hot
shot behind the counter bucking for a
promotion yeah call you out and
embarrass you in front of the whole taco
bell um maybe you don't give a [ __ ] but
fat guys
we don't like to be embarrassed
or drawing pay attention to ourselves
while we're eating that's yeah that's
also yeah i don't need to i don't yeah
that's skinny cool good-looking guy
stuff
i can't get away with that
you know
it's a bad look oh yeah i i don't know
i don't do that even when i was super
[ __ ] poor
i would
just buy the soda for 159 i feel like
you're a big water cup guy t-boned
uh i've done it i've dabbled yeah pulled
a couple one two three chipotle heist
can't do it walk out of there with a
water cup and a free tabasco
so many people steal the tabasco which
is crazy it's crazy they still put the
bottles out chipotle what are you doing
yeah what are you doing you idiots and
they have the green stuff too that
stuff's like gold
yeah i love that green green stuff ain't
too shitty but chipotle not gonna shake
a stick out i wouldn't kick that out of
bed either
um
all right let's see here
uh
this is johnny c first timer his
question is just pub cheese question
mark what's pub cheese beer cheese beer
cheese it's like the light fluffy uh
what spreadable uh-huh yeah where is it
what do you mean where is it is it at a
bar
no it's like uh it comes in like tubs
like this and you like spread it on
crackers and stuff oh [ __ ] yeah yeah i
didn't i didn't touch that like my
mid-20s i was if i stayed away from it i
thought that was like i thought there
was like horseradish sauce or something
i would love if there was horseradish
cheese i like pimento cheese too what's
that i think it's i thought it was that
[ __ ] i don't know my sister-in-law
always puts it out with her charcuterie
board and it's fantastic it looks just
like that oh pimento cheese is a little
more like mayo it's a little more pasty
maybe yeah i just thought it was it's
creamy it's chunky though creamy that's
what i meant creamy was the word
fantastic really yeah i [ __ ] love
that stuff pimento cheese sandwiches
back in the day i thought yeah i thought
you meant
is it like uh like uh like
the bars put out cheese on the bar i
know mcsorley's does that they put out
slices of cheese and an onion no that's
what you get when you order you order
food it comes with like a paper plate
with like two slices of cheese
three pieces of lettuce and onion it's
like toppings for a burger it's like a
nexium commercial yeah that's [ __ ] a
tough look
and beer but shout out to [ __ ] pub
cheese though say okay [ __ ] yeah
what about what about port cheese
what the they're it's the cheese that
has like a little red stuff in it no on
the outside it says red on the outside
and sometimes it's coated in nuts like a
cheese log coated in nuts what
it's like a half dome
yeah yeah yeah yeah what's it called
cheese pork port wine cheese or yeah
it's like red with walnuts on the
outside it's hella good it's very
similar in consistency to pub cheese
yeah no that looks like salami to me i'm
not [ __ ] with that [ __ ] kick rock on
a triscuit
no shout out to the triscuit i'm
straight up that's the same stuff with
the red stuff in it that comes in the
tub
now i don't do that i don't know that is
oh i know what you're talking about i
know what you're saying
i don't want any parts of that
nope i don't want raspberry in my cheese
yeah
that's a good sherbert on my crackers
kick rock are you a triscuits or a wheat
thin guy uh we were a triscuit household
still are shout out to the like the
rosemary olive oil the black
cracked pepper yeah get some real chew
out of a triscuit oh yeah it takes you a
minute
yeah it's all right it's like eating
cinnamon
the triscuit challenge
but i do like a wheat thin
sure wheat things are all right i need
something on the little meat on the bone
though you know what i mean you're a
triscuit man i am tristan we're a whole
triscuit family you go you go to the
pizza's house right now there's about
two three boxes of triscuits i don't
know lying and waiting i don't know if
it's cause i'm getting older or not but
i'm a big cheese and crackers
this and that kind of guy love love all
that [ __ ] love it just have that as a
meal oh i i have
wheat thin is just an npr cheez-it
though
sure
i guess you guys i know yeah i'm sorry
that
then we found comedy in the hanging out
to dry
um an npr
yeah
that's where you got that joke from
it's like a republican cheese ball am i
right
i know what you're saying but not really
no a cheese it no a cheese that stands
alone of course the cheese stands alone
of course you know what but i do
structurally
toby yes size wise
size that's it that's all they don't
have a little hole in the center and
they're
wheat thins are dense
yeah
and now i circle back on that joke that
thing stunk
it wasn't even factually correct
hey ira glass zip it will ya don't you
ever say anything bad about the jesus
of the cheese [ __ ] balls on this kid
all right this next one
[Applause]
next one
what just happened
i don't know man we're very defensive
against the cheez-it and when you
compare it to a [ __ ] trash cracker in
any form good or bad
yeah
you're gonna get some resistance i've
also had a problem with the npr
reference yeah it was also i feel
presented as a fact more than a joke
all right this is from ryan have you
ever used a t-shirt as a pillowcase [ __ ]
yeah yeah sometimes it's the best if you
i've done it where you get home and
you're drunk or something you're staying
in someone's head and it's like a little
sketchy and you got a fresh tea
tuck it right oh i've never done it for
those reasons what have you done it for
out of [ __ ] uh
pillowcases
that's what i'm saying but i've like if
somebody i've
i'll hang out on my friend or sleep at
my friend's house and they'll give me
like
a pillow with no pillowcase oh god
there's one in the closet and it's like
[ __ ] brown rings on it and stuff i'm
not that big of a pillowcase guy i'll be
honest with you
i could yeah i could really i can fly
with no sheet
not just on a bed yeah no pillowcase no
sheet as long as i got my comforter and
the fan next to me i'm golden you start
like waiting
you start sweating that's like a [ __ ]
exfoliator on your skin you're [ __ ] i
don't mind it's like a burlap sap yeah
so i don't need it do you have a
mattress cover there just a straight
mattress i could go straight mattress
mattress cover is one thing man cause
that's cotton that's okay that's not
yeah of course mattresses it's like a
sheet i might as well be a [ __ ] that's
like a duvet yeah those are nice yeah
but no i can go straight on the mattress
that's [ __ ] bonkers and sometimes i
like sleep with your socks on what am i
a [ __ ] [ __ ] no i take them off
when i get in bed and leave them at the
bottom i take them off with my piggies
you know what i mean you get in with
them oh yeah and then take them off take
them off talking about it talk about
[ __ ] popping molly that's a-okay
that's a good nothing
little heavy there
and then wrap the bottom flap of the
sheet of the comforter under my feet and
then i rub my feet together until i fall
asleep
wacko
i was up to i was up with you to the
[ __ ] pigs in a blanket
um i love taking my sakes off find them
in the sheets i get yelled at for it
i tell you lose socks
[Laughter]
[ __ ] in the sock
um
were you ever big on using the sock to
masturbate no doesn't i don't even
understand it i don't even know what
you're doing
what i'm doing now i go i've dabbled
it's not my forte i don't would you
you're using the sock as lubrication
i mean it's not it's not lubricant dress
sock what are you talking about dress uh
yeah i mean but who's who's got [ __ ]
dress socks is that just blue jean i got
one pair of them and i got a wedding
coming up
wearing nikes to a wedding
um
uh yeah
i've done it it's not a
never did that or like the um
like a piece of cantaloupe or something
like that
okay yeah people like to heat that up i
don't think people are really doing that
i think that's one of those like i think
they are
i think left to their own devices an
adolescent boy in a home alone does a
lot of weird [ __ ] that's
nuts to me i don't think that's a thing
you can ask my vacuum cleaner dirty
[ __ ]
shout out to mrs hoover
mrs hoover's in an open relationship
[Laughter]
mr hoover was working some long hours
when i was a kid
okay you and the boys sleepovers would
you do that
pull out the hoover [ __ ] suck each
other off take turns
take turns on the vacuum cleaner
when he's going to the nozzle when he's
going in the bristles has to change the
bag
you remember remember vacuum cleaner
bags
they were real trashy i never we'd run
out of bags we're out of bags everybody
runs out
and there was a thing i don't know where
you get them i don't do i think you
needed a [ __ ] engineer to put one in
i remember i tried one one time and it
just opened up and there was five i
looked like a mummy afterwards i was
covered in grey dust what the [ __ ] is
this not gonna shower trying to [ __ ]
trying to get my dick sucked
now all of a sudden i gotta [ __ ] [ __ ]
my mom will be home in 15 minutes
you shower coat my hair
kevin why is the vacuum cleaner full of
dress socks
[Music]
that is a good time
kevin why is the vacuum cleaner smoking
behind the house
vacuum cleaner using a vibrator
[Laughter]
oh we're having fun here gang this is
what we do over here on the
uh this one i know for sure has
resonated with both of us uh from danny
rosa uh are you still holding on to
clothes that don't fit because you're
gonna lose the weight
a lifelong fat guy
buddy i'm holding on a [ __ ] from college
still i gotta i got a couple pairs of
jeans wait till i lose 15 pounds i'm
gonna be out of here stunting
dude i got a couple of pairs of jeans
that i'm [ __ ] waiting yeah break out
i'll i got them in glass with a little
hammer next to them
next to the jesus
i'll go one better
i've bought clothes
and been like oh wait till i lose weight
that's really gonna look good jesus yeah
like every one of those hawaiian shirts
kimmy's got six pair of bell bottoms
[Laughter]
a couple of pair of jankas
yeah man that's my whole closet
the stuff that doesn't fit a hundred
percent like i have i have a pretty big
like double door closet
uh full of dreams
[Laughter]
full of skeletons and dreams
yeah man
they're either but here's the thing i
have to go through them because the
shirts most 90 of them got stains on
them
and patty i'll tell you what the paint a
lot of the pants have rips
it's a in them
the crotch rip
you can save them a little bit you get
one or two just like she used to be
though yeah you're limping one side it's
weird it's like when you break a bone
she's never as strong as she was like a
racehorse
yeah that's my whole [ __ ] world like
i literally probably have like six pairs
six
articles of clothing
sure i don't have a lot either i have a
couple pairs
of uh
cargos but now they're starting to get
old too like the one pair ripped
that's why i didn't sit down in boston
because i had a rip in my thing now i
had undies on
but yeah they're starting to go too and
i was poking around on target.com i
think they discontinued them i don't
know where i'm going to go for my car
why don't you go to the big and tall
their pants are weird these are like
they hurt i don't understand yeah these
are these are double xls these are
double xl cargos off the rack at target
they're made by um
good penis what are you talking about
huh there's no way those are double xl
they're double xl
make them loose
and they [ __ ] fit me perfectly
i can't find them i would argue they
don't fit perfectly if you rip them
constantly that's just just wear and
tear i wear i wear these gray ones
almost every day that's a lot of wear
and tear though you're putting extra
tear on city miles too yeah yeah yeah
there's no country ride on sunday i'll
tell you that
um all right this one's from stephen new
patreon here have you ever gotten
catfished at sport clips selecting the
stylist on the sign in terminal now we
have to unpack this a little bit i don't
fully know what the [ __ ] he's talking i
know exactly what he's talking about
because i know one gentleman that used
to get his haircut it supports you
really it'd be like a saturday night for
him you're kidding me i take him in
there he wants to go
15 minutes is for the appointment he
sits there he reads a magazine he chats
it up with the broads so what you guys
watch a sports center some sort of
self-service like
kiosk where you where you sign in it's
like a girl or
and then debbie comes out as a [ __ ]
warlock
but her picture she was a [ __ ] 10
piece
is that what i'm picking up here if you
want to put it that way yeah sure okay i
don't see things like that yeah yeah 100
i was a big uh all
in high school and
college
hair cuttery guy because the girls that
i
graduated with all worked at a haircut
so it was like
i would i wasn't going to haircut i was
going to them if that makes sense yeah i
got you um sports clips is really
something else
it's real [ __ ] trash
i feel all of them they cut a good hair
though do they dad used to come out
looking good and you know what they this
is a little bit sketchy
i've never been
a shampoo guy
when i go to get a haircut hey [ __ ]
never am i never anywhere that we got
our hair cut growing up was a shampoo on
the [ __ ] table it was some vietnam
that
didn't want to [ __ ] touch you yeah
all right now you got these places like
super cuts and [ __ ] super clips where
they give you the whole thing they take
in the back they [ __ ] shampoo they
blow dry you mm-hmm it's all [ __ ]
sure i go right home and who the [ __ ]
not going home and taking a shower yes
that's what i wanted i guess women
aren't because it's not as
different women aren't going to super
clips
strategy ones are yeah yeah and you have
a haircut of a pit boss come on that's
not like objects aren't the blazer at
all
yeah that's for like women like you know
65 and older they got the same haircut
their husbands do
yeah nobody's going in there yes of
course
ladies go and get their hair done
you don't have to take a shower sure but
you get a haircut you go to the [ __ ]
home and take a shower tyler like you
want some product product what do you
think i'm [ __ ] going out of it yeah
yeah i do whatever
all night once a year i'll get that
t-shirt's ruined anyway yeah yeah yeah
you can't wear that once a year i'll get
hemmed up and be like oh i gotta do it
just because the schedule and it's the
only time i can go i have something
something something and i hate it you
don't feel right to take that shower the
haircut's not done it's not what you
think
it needs to wash it needs to settle
you've got clippings in your ears and
[ __ ] like that
no yeah i have to stop i have to [ __ ] so
bad this is crazy
really
all right what do you got all right this
is from chris scott uh you or anyone in
your family ever given or received a
hickory forms box
it's like the [ __ ]
the moving question yeah what i'm gonna
do a big big hickory farms huge does
anybody ever really eat it though [ __ ]
yeah
i don't see them strawberry candies that
they get them little jaws come on what
the [ __ ] are we talking about that was
for the kids i loved they would put them
in the four corners of the box that was
like fruit in our house that was like
through two to three servings of those
things today good night
those things were dude the wooden box
the [ __ ] uh the kielbasa the cheese
that's where you'd find the cheese
cheese and the pimento cheese yes
yes yeah i remember when that was that
was a place
there was salesmen in there you'd walk
in they'd have all the displays
something like the wooden crate with
like the staple like this that's what
i'm saying yeah man you get one you send
one of those at christmas time in the
80s
[ __ ] classy
yeah used to get them all the time we
still get them i think i love it
hickory farms might be an east coast
thing i don't know
i'm not sure it's like a gift for the
the listener if you're not from it's
like a gift pack it has like some sort
of cure there's a store in the mall
was it in the mall that's what i'm
saying yeah i don't remember that oh
[ __ ] store in the mall damn you'd
walk in
that gift it was like cured meats some
cheeses some candies like a harry potter
popcorn or something who's the guy it's
like a harry and david's the [ __ ] who
the [ __ ] are harry and david oh they
make a moose track popcorn that'll blow
your hair back that's who harry and
david is they do gift baskets okay
they do get but not with not with cured
meats hickory farms is really centered
around that
the bee stick
they really yeah they really cornered
the uh cured meats
yeah yeah that's what built them we
might we used to cook hickory farms
that's how trashy we were i don't even
know what that like the the log that log
you would get would you throw it on a
grill
no we'd slice it and fry it up and my
aunt would take
my aunt would take uh take that or take
it out of the wrapper first
she would take uh
ketchup
and like brown or whatever else it's
brown
and it would make like a sauce with it
that sauce ain't too shabby though no
it's almost like a swedish meatball yes
i know exactly what you're talking about
i was just down in the dr they had some
sort of meeting that read something like
that
i wasn't i wasn't throwing rocks at it
yeah it ain't too big
but yeah we would do that cooking
hickory farms that's pretty trashy and i
remember one time her making it and
there wasn't a holiday to be seen it was
just like
it was just just [ __ ] yeah and she
was firing that up for lunch
i wasn't complaining that's a bad luck i
love it i don't remember us ever really
eating it uh i'm sure my pa my st my
stepdad would eat anything growing up
uh one aunt census sends a nice basket
from this place in philly called
carlino's okay i hope they don't mind me
saying their name shout out to it they
care you just said the product was great
unbelievable
unbelievable stuff yeah nice okay like
hickory forms on a real class level
not too shabby not too
shabby uh but i wish that stuff would
come back more i like that
i like sending baskets and getting fancy
people do it you're just a dirtbag yeah
okay and also you don't have a lot of
relationships where that would be
appropriate
i'm sure your parents get them sure your
parents send them aunts uncles like for
business like i know like when i used to
work for my phone we would send them to
like our clients like we would go to
this place what about them
chocolate-covered strawberries they
ain't too shabby
trying to [ __ ] me
chocolate-covered strawberries you're
trying to [ __ ] oh when a sleeve of those
would show up at the house
good night um edible arrangements edible
undies
every arrangement is edible to you
get out of the lilies
i got it for my wife for [ __ ]
valentine's day stems and all this fat
little prick he's bitching about uh the
[ __ ] thorns in his tongue
i don't know
i remind you i'm i'm guy fieri
michael this is a fat tubby [ __ ]
this guy fieri michael is real fair
piece of [ __ ] that's what we do on the
road for the listener when me and foley
are in the front seat we just do intros
the diners drives in and dives the whole
time
they were at this [ __ ] here in st
louis
where they make an atomic burger i don't
know what the [ __ ] that is but i told
him i'd try it for him get a couple of
heads for the door holy's gonna try to
eat eight of them yeah also guy fieri is
from chicago is he no
but you guys always doing the chicago
accent
hey listen buddy it's the sauce tickles
the funny bone
uh all right let's see this one's from
tj home run ever fallen through ice
[Music]
buddy if you're if you get yourself a
position when you're falling through ice
you're doing something wrong you're not
playing by the book it's on a dare
[Laughter]
see if i do it man i was pet i was
petrified my parents made me
hyper scared of a few things which i
appreciated all right now i don't they
might have to
they took some liberties and now the
[ __ ]
patient's running the asylum wearing
your seatbelt drunk driving like are we
all drunk driving no no listen if you're
gonna get all [ __ ] up on schlitz and
drive home at least put your seatbelt on
you could do the cuff where you put him
behind him
no
not where always to wear your seatbelt
never drink and drive [ __ ]
in the ocean i feel like i could be
taken before i even hit the water that i
could just be yanked out from the fear
they put in sure you're not that fun of
a hang that's what you're getting at
dude i was i was walking past a guy on
the street the other day who goes nah
nah the water's warmer they're getting
closer you go in there you lose a foot
that's crazy
to be afraid of sharks
what
if there's a shark sighting
what kind of [ __ ] are you you're in
their turf
they're everywhere they're not first of
all they're not everywhere yes they are
yes they are but define everywhere my
brother's uh
my brother's old neighbor
kid's a lifeguard i heard this just got
attacked by her this snoozefest just got
tired fought the shark off swam back
[ __ ] tough yeah he was like 250 yards
out and he's a lifeguard yeah
yeah how many lifeguards are getting
attacked that i'm saying that's an
anomaly i'm still worrying when i'm in
the lazy river
you worry about in a bathtub i used to
when i was a kid and i would go in the
pool i would be you'd bring a harpoon
gun
[Laughter]
hate your dad
shout out big man i we used to go in the
pool i used to look like you know at the
other end of the pool and i could swear
i see a shark swimming towards you it
was [ __ ] jaws everybody [ __ ]
kisses spielberg's ass he gave [ __ ] a
whole generation [ __ ] phobias we're
scared to death
no [ __ ] sharks you're crazy that's
what it is anybody who was a kid when
jaws came out you're ruined from the
ocean i don't care who you are that's
not true nobody's swimming
what do you mean nobody's swimming
millions of people go in the ocean
in the state of new jersey a day taking
their life in their hands
they're everywhere check jersey when the
last person killed by a shark was in new
jersey attacked
attacked well hey i mean hey things
happen i mean what are we talking about
get drunk at a bar
he could be get roughed up in a bar if
you want to get roughed up in an arcade
if you're [ __ ] staring at the wrong
guy
and especially in hawaii i won't go
[ __ ] near that water i'll look at it
it's beautiful
i'll dive into a lagoon i'm not swimming
in the pacific ocean
kidding me dive into a lagoon who are
you the skipper that's why they got the
boys on the indianapolis over there
all right it says there have been four
incidents in the last 10 years in new
jersey four incidents divided incidents
one sexual harassment
the other was drunk driving
domestic
disturbance what only one resulted in an
injury
but but no but this is one injury this
is big shark in their spin zone trying
to run their propaganda hammerhead inks
running the hoop who printed that
is that
it's the [ __ ] was that the mako
chronicle who did that
shark tooth weekly
mr foley jimmy betch from shark tooth
magazine
we're taking a bite out of the story
here
that's [ __ ] big tourism saying that
just like in jaws they had to keep the
beaches open
didn't help the little kitten boy i'll
tell ya
he probably did something bad in another
lifetime if you ask me he had the hex on
him from jump street ah that kidner boy
god damn it
i didn't pull any punches on that either
i was that kid's age i think when that
came out
the [ __ ] out dig me a hole on the beach
and fill it up tubby i ain't going in
the water let me know what are you
calling tubby
is there a guy fatter than you on the
beach when i was a kid yeah
[ __ ] that
no that's just dipping dots protecting
their investment no you're you're nuts
that's exactly what it is
never had dippin dots either
we'll get some at the wildwood boardwalk
spoiler alert
comment
hitting the boards hitting the boards
and the ocean i'm not going on the water
you're not going in the water you have
to go in the water man you have to go in
the water dude no
yeah go in the pool no you got to go in
the water for a while fine then i'm
bringing my shark uh scent repellent
that i have so if he's coming to those
cages
i'm dragging him down the beach
he's eating soft serving chain mail
i'm gonna finish this and take a dip
[ __ ] ain't gonna get me i'll tell you
that
look like i'm in king arthur's court
i got a shield and a [ __ ] sword kippy
do you have a tank connect down there
who fills up your tanks for you
[Laughter]
i don't do it i don't go in the ocean i
respect the ocean i respect it as well
it is a great hang on listen you're
going in the water
i know i'll go in a motel pool no you
got to go in the water for the video
yeah
maybe
body surf i'll surf you i like body
surfing dude on that i'll paddle usually
as a paddleboard
yeah yeah we'll get you a boogie board
no that that do you look like you look
like i got an old door or something
like titanic out there he's the hood of
my car you don't use boogie boards
because that you look like a guy you
look like a seat i know i've watched
shark week you [ __ ] bozo yeah none of
that
that's ins that's in [ __ ] australia
or south africa fannie i'll go out there
and like [ __ ] camouflage they won't
see me coming
dressed like another shark ah nothing to
see here folks
hey keep it moving teddy hey how about
these people
stink right see you next week at the
meeting all right
i don't like it they move too quick and
you know what i read too that's a staple
they can smell a cheeseburger a mile
away in the water you know what i read
that made me even more scared
is
down there
there where's down there in the water in
the water oh my god you are a trashy
smarted person
down in the water in the water they're
used to the the
that uh pressure
so when they move
they move real fast in that pressure
humans aren't used to that kind of
pressure so we move slower so they even
have more of an advantage on you if they
want to get the jump on you sure
also too you can't see them and they're
attacking you from underwater and they
have to yeah i mean there's
a lot of factors but that's one of them
they're like super with their
where you just call a shark superhuman
yeah
they have like super powers because of
the because of the pressure because
you're not used to moving in that kind
of pressure so you're slow i'm the one
that can breathe underwater start with
that one not the pressure also they're
not human
they're sharks you understand yeah
they're mammals
right for something to be super human
would have to be human fine they're
super sharks
and you are super
dumb
either way i don't like sharks i'm
scared of sharks i'm sorry have you ever
seen a shark yeah where i'm not in
another [ __ ] camden aquarium
you've never seen an actual shark i have
somebody they caught one in the [ __ ]
on the bay in ocean city when we were
staying at the harbor house one year how
big
it was enough to [ __ ] bite me i don't
know it was like maybe like that big
that's what you're afraid what are you
first of all it just got three feet
bigger the second time
it was this one
dude a shark like that's a sand shark no
they're real cute i like them catching
them yeah they have no teeth
they're so cute
just like the dyson
i got a sand shark on my johnson
all right listen you're going in the
water and that's deep how did we start
to oh fall into the fall through ice
yeah yeah that's a tough look
that's instant petrifying that's another
thing that my parents [ __ ] instilled
in me yeah basically if i fell through
the ice i knew i was dying yeah we used
to have uh
uh
we used to go to a house up the
mountains on lake wall and paul pack
know it well and uh
that's a big mamajama of a lake monster
huge i don't like lakes either hundreds
of yards wide at points like i mean like
there's too many weird things in there
and the grass comes up in there and
touches your piggies we would walk on
the we go up in the winter and we'd walk
on it out i mean i remember so you would
see like cracks
not like
pressure like i don't know but it would
be like this thick it would you know
you'd be able to see down at least like
a foot i'm like oh we're all right so
we're like let's see how far we can go
and we are
dude my butthole puckered up so i
[ __ ] hightailed it out of there i was
like no way yeah
um the kid that fell through the ice
yeah you ever gone down a youtube rabbit
hole of like how to get out of ice if
you fall through or like what to do if
you're in quicksand or some [ __ ] i've
got the ice thing you're supposed to
like go back to where you came what
because when you
sounded racial
talk about ice right when you fall
through the ice you kind of you move and
don't realize it so you're not right
above the same hole so you got to find
that hole and go back through it
and then it's like surface pressure it's
like surface area that's the problem
like if you see like even in parks like
in the like uh in central park and stuff
like that in the park [ __ ] people go
down and those things every [ __ ]
winter the latter thing that you like
you [ __ ]
because if a person gets close then they
fall in yeah so it's like they have a
ladder thing that you can like hold on
to and they'll pull you out type deal
yeah yeah i don't thought that what i
don't get
is we should be more afraid of ice
falling on the ice than sharks
i'm scared of both of them sure sharks
under the ice i get out of the ice
double whammy i can't fight a shark hold
on the shark's not attacking the ice is
actively attacked what about ice sharks
the ice is attacking you or the shark is
attacking you what's he doing hanging
out i've been in that i know there's
sharks i'm saying the probability of a
shark attack is way less than you
standing on ice and falling in an ice
probably i agree with there's a truck
under the ice we've talked about this on
the ride home from boston you are both
crazy
sharks under the ice what are we doing
if you're in a yeah what do you mean
what
sharks could swim under the ice
so now you're afraid of falling through
the ice and also getting caught by a
shark yeah just to find out where in
foleyville i am
does that sound about right we're in the
end we're in the antarctic you're right
down there on main street okay
all right well
wait hold on i wanted to say something
eye sharks don't seem to be real but
there is a tv movie from 2016 called ice
sharks got 3 out of 10 stars looks
pretty good
[Laughter]
mario lopez in it if so i'm in
that kid lights up the screen what i was
gonna say what's that
is that it's weird that
hypothermia is what kills you when you
fall into the ice sure but now people do
the ice bath so how come nobody's dying
in ice baths it's time i mean you're in
an ice bath for a very relatively short
period of time oh really yeah i mean
you're not like so eventually that would
kill you yeah if you i think if you sit
in there for 30 minutes or so yeah i
thought that's how much you did it
didn't rogan do it for like 20 minutes i
don't have all the answers but i'm
saying there's a specific difference
than falling in a lake and getting
hypothermia then
also it's the clothing that gets you
it's the cotton sucks all the heat out
of you once it gets wet yeah so you're
better off getting completely naked and
trying to re-heat yourself now we're
talking when you are done
then you're naked for the shark though
you get a little worm hanging out that's
like bait you're trolling for that i
don't like that
um all right let's run through a couple
more here this is uh run before it's too
late you ever your group ever get kicked
off the go-karts
[Laughter]
for sure that's a bad look
go-karts and bumper carts i've been
asked to leave yeah yeah yeah um for
sure this next one's great oh sorry guys
i was gonna say i've had the guy you
ever have the dude come and jump on your
[ __ ] bumper car uh and like try to
steer
you [ __ ] no hitchers
throw it in reverse real quick [ __ ]
jerk him off get the bricks dirt bag
yeah
uh the next one is from uh the savage
cabbage do you or anyone in your family
have a wallet that's way too thick
oh yeah he also used the wrong two by
the way which shout out to that
my dad forever yeah my stepdad's got a
hefty one happily have to my dad just
always did cards and then money which i
got that i don't like a wallet i can't
[ __ ] with
i have a wallet now that i would like to
replace but i can't replace it because
i feel like a wallet i haven't lost this
wallet ever
so you feel if you buy a new wallet
you'll lose it yes
foleyville
i'm just telling you how it is
i don't know that's how the sharks are
gonna get here
sharks gonna steal my identity next
thing you know i gotta go i gotta go to
the aquarium have them sorted out
i can't even make it to atlantis i can't
hold my breath excuse me sir one of them
tiger shark stole my wallet
and that grouper has my phone
what
grouper
thank you i almost ordered some this
week some grouper shout out to the group
kenny cooper why
because i even know what it is they
can't piss off two sharks then they'll
really be after me
if the sharks find out that kippy's
eating group they got it out for me you
leave all the fish in the ocean
plenty of food
i don't need to go looking at me
you go in the water she just ends up you
and a mako fighting over a
seal you're both breaching
nothing on breaching oh all right let's
see uh let's get serious here okay oh
this is on brandon's podcast here this
is from owen have you or anyone in your
family ever taken a [ __ ] in the ocean
i mean my family's big enough and we're
beach people i'm sure
i'm assuming somebody in my bloodline i
couldn't do it i couldn't do it either
yeah holy cat [ __ ] in the ocean that's
like the exxon valdez
i have to call fema
gotta have a couple of scientists come
in and plug that thing all right i like
him i don't hate it i don't hate it
somebody get his underpants there's
already poop in him
sure i think he's gonna blow
somebody get the president on the phone
[Music]
and that's another thing too what is it
how do you know it's gonna be a perfect
log not to be gross i don't think it
matters well if it's diarrhea you're in
it it's all over you you can't yeah put
that away at that it's like p they i
mean the [ __ ] parts per million it
gets all [ __ ] up you got to swim
around a little bit oh yeah i mean you
you can't go rolling back to the
volleyball game
no you take a couple of dips yeah
you swim downstream you find a way to
karen's going and then you make your
move hopefully a riptide comes in takes
it out
that's disgusting yeah
uh let's see this is from
tire tyr uh first question ever buy
fetish urine to pass a drug test did you
say fetish urine i guess this is news to
me what if you're into pee stuff you can
buy pee
which i'm assuming that's what this
gentleman's talking about but how would
you know it's clean
there he is i'm sure it's certified
somewhere certified if you're like
buying it from a reputable establishment
i'm sure it's not whole foods
i'm sure it's packaged i don't think
it's in like a i don't think you're
buying it in like a soda can like an
open soda cake oh it's a mason jar like
a gentleman man i picture like a bottle
like a farm to table
from free range [ __ ]
[Laughter]
um
if you're if you're selling your piss on
the internet there's no way that's clean
yeah that's what i'm saying i don't know
but i'm assuming maybe they test it
before they tell me like hey this is
drug free this this chick has diabetes
oh there you go you know i don't know
what i mean why are we drawing the line
if fetish p is a thing i'm sure there's
levels to what people well it's great
that that's out there it's great that
[ __ ] people could do that so you
don't have to hit up a buddy
sure i was always that guy of like yo i
might need pee
tomorrow i gotta save my p.o a lot all
my friends had pos
as high schoolers had parole officers
probation officers yikes yeah i don't
think i've ever had to
take a drug test
i think in the playoffs my freshman
playoffs
[Laughter]
in the playoffs there was fear of that
sure your hammer was going to come down
that whole team would have been [ __ ]
of course and they know what they're
doing yeah look the other way let the
kids smoke a little reefer yeah you know
what i mean
um this is a perfect segue this is like
the [ __ ] show a segway show this is
from braxton uh did your parents ever
buy an at-home drug test for you or your
siblings oh man
that's [ __ ] american beauty [ __ ] no
we never had that parents played it cool
yeah my mom
she knew we were
dabbling or so
never came up with my parents the only
time it did come up she just didn't ask
questions also yeah you know as long as
like hey you're not a [ __ ]
high school drop like you're getting
you're not you're not spiking up you're
a productive member of society sure if
you're [ __ ] functional you're you're
puffing a little cheaper having a couple
of [ __ ] mg dizzles it don't matter
um sorry for not locking the
refrigerator uh
but she came up to me one time i don't
know if i ever told you this she came up
to me one time with a post-it note it
said hydro and mids
and she was like what does this mean
my brother was like home from college or
something i was probably like 16 maybe
or 15 i don't know and i was like yeah
what does that mean what i don't know do
you know i don't know anything about it
probably
he's like probably the neighbors
the way you can just go into a lie is
scaring me yeah um so it says hydro or
me when it comes it's like your back's
up against the wall so it says hydro or
mids couple world war ii pilots i think
so i go like
i don't i'm like
i think what i think is she heard my
brother on the phone going is that hydro
or mitch what is she the [ __ ] school
newspaper no i'm not hey nancy drew take
it easy
stick to happy hour what you know all
right try to [ __ ] play detective on
us
hey mako times
[Laughter]
um so i was like respectful to the peace
i apologize she doesn't listen she
wouldn't know where to find the show um
not with those detective skills
she goes what is she goes do you know
what this is so i go i don't know what
that is i go ask danny did you not know
did i not know i was high as a kite put
it by a [ __ ] square i was [ __ ]
growing it in the attic i cannot know
smoking weed i've been smoking weeds
that's been smoking weed okay
you're smoking a joint as she was saying
that that's [ __ ] up i don't know
god damn you got me
[ __ ] crazy though
[Laughter]
so she finally went to ah she went to
danny and he was just like yeah what
he's like the hikers i'll tell you the
hydros are way better than the mids
talking about a guy not karen
uh here it was some she heard somebody
it's her
co-worker hers heard her son on the
phone going is it hydra or mids first of
all
if you can't tell by the price that if
it's hydromids you're getting bamboozled
to begin with all right your kids are
you're a [ __ ] greenhorn your kids are
your kids a real bubble gummer
lady hey chess club kick [ __ ] rocks
we're trying to party over here you're
[ __ ] brickweed
trying to get lit
ah that's good no we only uh
we got busted at a party my sophomore
year
pretty heavy yeah cops came in
yeah nothing happened yeah they took us
in a paddy wagon to the police station
foley and two other guys with 40s taped
to their hands
it's a real rager can you pull my pants
up
officer watch out their [ __ ] my
underwear don't tell nobody
hey they might have caught me on the
underage drinking but they didn't get me
for [ __ ]
i didn't rat okay
nobody was none away you may stink like
[ __ ] i may be full of [ __ ] but i ain't
no rat
no we got [ __ ] hauled down and uh
they found um
uh a pipe
and then we [ __ ] [ __ ] oh there's
older kids [ __ ] this always the older
kids yeah take a walk flat foot you know
i can't say the word till i see a
detective's badge okay
i talked to my lawyer
what is his body full but no then one of
my boys left that pipe in their [ __ ]
glove compartment
and their mom was like [ __ ] tooling
around doing errands one day and she
finds that in a sock yeah we were out
mini golfing at [ __ ] uh at woody's
sound like a couple of cool guys
they get in the clown's mouth you
[ __ ] dork
well we were getting the game in before
the friday night
oh man you paint this picture of being a
[ __ ] cool guy meanwhile you're
getting wedgies at the [ __ ] local
putt-putt course
because that's a cool kid doesn't mean
i'm like a twist cone once in a while
and a [ __ ] windmill
but we got a call everybody's got to
come to [ __ ] so-and-so's house so we
all go in there
i was dealing with some serious people
the gentleman i was interacting was a
lawyer
high priced lawyer i'm sure he knew what
the deal was what do you mean the
gentleman you were interacting with the
the one kid that my kid's dad yeah he's
the one that ran the meeting it was all
our parents all sitting around ah oh
yeah anytime my parents met other
parents you're [ __ ] hemmed off they
were all there we pulled in all of our
parents cars are there we're like [ __ ]
this ain't coming yep busted you easy
spain handed out 20s
it's funny there's always that one kid's
parents that just never showed up like
you're one dirtbag buddy yeah you're
looking at them
really they wouldn't comment your
parents got all rounded up oh yeah if
you guys all got in trouble she would
show up oh yeah she should have a couple
in here
i'm going to tell her you said that what
a little [ __ ] do now
[Laughter]
this is about a little bit to do now
all right
i don't know how that's supposed to make
me feel
you're out of kahlua and kevin
[Laughter]
you got as long as this drink has tell
me what the fat little [ __ ] did
otherwise i gotta get back to work all
right
i'm so upset right now
ah
t-bone
to kahlua
talking about bottom of the knife it
makes up for the [ __ ] npr joke i
don't know what you're talking about
for the listener he has to see the real
tapes
you want to you want the double you want
you're not redacted
t-bone released the tapes
i thought i felt the chair going for a
second
it's close that day is the day we go
viral viral
that'll be unreleased
anyway
they started grilling us about it we
played stupid they broke it in front of
us he snapped it in front of us oh real
tough guy
[ __ ] loser
it wasn't great man um
i [ __ ] got through calling my mom a
[ __ ] lush for 45 seconds i made fun
of some no
i know you say that about this guy you
don't know
ah
and that was it oh great
nobody said it never got caught [ __ ]
doing anything yeah never had to take a
drug test or whatever
and we were pretty cool about stuff
we were [ __ ] animals we weren't
[ __ ] building a half pipe in the
living room
might have been a bottle of secrets
missing or two here but what are you
gonna do seagram's was big back then
seagram's man i couldn't even look at it
my parents went to like new hope for the
day and me and my three buddies [ __ ]
decided to [ __ ] knock off a fifth of
[ __ ] secrets for no reason sure
middle of a sunday my brother comes home
from playing football he starts [ __ ]
beating the [ __ ] out of me i'm yakking
in the [ __ ] sink [ __ ] brutal yeah
you're drinking bumpy are you drinking a
bumpy face secret gin
no no no secrets whiskey
77 with the trust of lemon
um nothing wrong with it we were maybe
not even [ __ ] we were maybe 12 and my
buddy's sister bought us
seagram wine coolers they were they were
nice and i just remember being like we
are way too young
for you to be buying us booze lady i
know i'll listen i asked for she 21 yeah
oh that's a [ __ ] up family
yeah an 11 year gap in [ __ ] ages come
on yeah i think it ended up being like a
27 year gap total um
but it was just like uh i remember being
like what i remember we were sitting up
in his attic drinking them i'm like this
is bad this isn't good we should i gotta
get out of situations like this my mom's
gotta ask some questions i gotta go back
to school yeah i gotta do something
all right let's wrap it up gang listen
we love you we appreciate you thank you
everybody uh for supporting us thank you
everybody that came to the live show
thanks for everybody that's gonna come
to a live show come out and see the
[ __ ] gangs the boys we'll be back
next week kippy you got anything for
them uh just always make sure to take
them out great review subscribe on
itunes full video available on youtube
uh patreon guys the merch is only gonna
be available maybe for another two three
weeks so get on yeah while it's
available we haven't even been pushing
it and it's moving yeah so get the
[ __ ] merch uh the beer koozies and
the cards
also uh like we said live shows we have
texas coming up we have philly chaos we
have philly coming up we have long
island coming up we're playing an nyc
show planning we're trying to get
everywhere so uh yeah come out and see
us philly you better show the [ __ ] up
yeah we got something special yeah we do
all right see us we love you we'll see
you next week